good morning john we got a question in
the dear hank and john inbox oh who's it
from it's from debbie and it is a
question that i've been asking myself
for decades now we can spell letters
with letters
which is just i don't know what that
means but it just makes my brain go
and how they are spelled is of course
impacted by how they are pronounced and
there are ways
that we have decided to pronounce them
and i'm gonna rank them now so first of
all coming in at number one we have all
of the vowels they get to do whatever
they want coming in at number two we
have consonants that end in the
e noise so c t v b you're all fantastic
this makes perfect sense why
don't we just carry it through the whole
alphabet a you can do whatever you want
b c d e fee fee why not why
why but okay if we're gonna have another
system which it turns out we actually
have to because i'll get to that in a
second coming in at number three
we have the f the m the n the
s where instead of coming at the
beginning of the word we decide we're
going to put the consonant at the end of
the word and i was thinking about this
and i was why can't we just switch all
of these over to like the bcd
version and then i got to s which if you
do that with
s you get c come on but there's another
letter for which this is true
and that is a number four along with k
we have j j and k they do their own
thing
and k could be key and that would be
great but j can't be g
because we got a g and then we got this
little island of misfit toys letters
that are not pronounced like any of the
other letters so coming into number five
we're going with q
i feel like q makes sense for it to be
weird like i don't know that we need q
like we could just use other letters to
do that like queen
k-w-e-e-n then we have x also is
standing around here on it joan because
it shouldn't exist
it's just ks or z for some reason and
now we have approached our final three
the worst clearly the worst letter names
why
which could have been ye
and we just missed that unacceptable but
not as bad as second to last
h h h doesn't even have
the h noise in it unless you're british
and you say h which
great good obviously that's what we
should do but that's not what we do
but but but h at least contains the
letter
h right it's there at the end but coming
in absolute
dead last just despicable
we have the only three syllable letter
the only letter
that references another letter the only
letter that does not even contain itself
w
it just describes its own shape but
poorly look there's a reason why we
ended up with w
and a spoiler it's not a great reason it
is
depending on how you count it the
youngest letter and it arrived in its
final form after the invention of the
printing press and so it was named
by printers who before we had ws would
just use
two u's instead of a w to make the one
noise like we still have a word that
does this equus
why is a w a double v hank well because
v's and u's were for a while kind of
interchangeable
i have a pet theory and there's nothing
supporting this that printers just had
more v's lying around because use were
more useful so using 2us all the time
would use up all of their use and did i
make the whole video so that i could say
that line a little
a little bit yeah john it's the last day
of the year when you can join the
awesome socks club at awesomesocks.com
or because these news are
interchangeable awesomestocks.com
log brothers be delighted with a new
pair of socks designed by a different
artist every month of 2021 except
if you sign up now it will not be every
month it will be two pairs in february
because we ran out of socks
and so they will be delivered two pairs
on february and then one every month
after that and know that all the profits
will be going to decrease maternal and
child mortality in sierra leone you can
sign up now or
tell someone you love to maybe sign you
up now at awesomes.club
slash oolong brothers john at the end of
your last video you asked
what's next and i love it and all i
gotta say is whatever it is
ain't gonna be little i'll see you on
tuesday